[Music]
oh
[Music]
[Music]
okay so the internet keeps on
internetting and new footage of harry
styles appearing to spit on chris pine
has been shared worldwide across twitter
it's the spit heard around the world
with a popping up everywhere online like
a live jasmine ad and it may be the
biggest thing to ever happen ever in the
last hour however there may be a totally
innocent explanation to it all we've
slowed down the footage analyzed it over
and over watching it more times in our
videos with our ex-girlfriend back when
we were happy together and have brought
you something that you might not have
noticed so don't worry darling we've got
you covered and if you enjoy this video
then please hit the thumbs up button and
make sure you subscribe because we're
almost at the million i promise i'll
stop doing these stupid breakdowns if we
hit that so yeah make sure make sure you
subscribe now according to the internet
we watch as chris claps away and we then
see harry appear to spit in his slap
which makes him stop clapping chris then
smirks as if he's just been offended and
then tries to laugh it off like it's the
reviews for star trek into darkness
however let's rewatch the footage with a
focus on what chris is looking at rather
than harry go on take your eyes off
harry styles you dirty
anyway we can see in his hands that he's
holding what appears to be a phone he
then places it in his lap and then also
looks down to see what's on the screen
at this point he then seems to get a
notification which makes him stop
clapping watch this again with all this
in mind and you can see that kevin's
spoilers has solved it case closed
however he does then take out this
object again showing that it's in fact
sunglasses and dun dun dun this confirms
that he has edit technology now honestly
i don't really know what's going on here
and we actually have footage from
another angle that makes it appear
completely innocent after the pair sits
down the pair seemed to chat away rather
than it all blowing up out of proportion
like that on the internet however there
is a lot of drama floating around the
premiere with already gaining numerous
headlines in case you don't know don't
worry darling has had a really awkward
production with there being lots of
behind the scenes tensions on the movie
during production olivia wilde was
actually served papers by her ex jason
sudokus and he said that he wanted
custody of their children in 2021 shia
labeouf was fired from the movie and
this happened after he apparently
clashed with olivia wilde on set
although the initial reason for his
leaving was said to be down to
scheduling conflicts wild did come out
and say that this wasn't true according
to marie claire she stated his process
was not conductive to the ethos that i
demand in my productions he has a
process that in some ways seems to
require combative energy and i don't
personally believe that it's conductive
to the best performances nailing the
accent i believe that creating a safe
trusting environment is the best way to
get people to do their work ultimately
my responsibility is to the production
and to the case to protect them that was
my job now while they ended up
requesting harry styles in the film and
the pair are now dying however to add
more fuel to the fire luber fired back
by saying that he'd in fact quit he
provided evidence to the outlet variety
showing that wild had sought to make a
wig with him and that she'd also
downplayed florence pew a bit who is
starring in the film this has led to
there being a ton of drama intentions on
set for the film but it's constantly
getting updates that it's going down as
well as the rings of power which i
actually like so anyway laurence has
done little to no promotion for the film
and whilst this is said to be because
she's currently working on the june
sequel you know the internet loves to
run olivia wilde with gossip so it's
made things a lot worse
while actually got asked about this in a
press junket recently and here's what
she had to say florence is a force and
we are so grateful that she's able to
make it tonight despite being in
production on dune i know as a director
how disruptive it is to lose an actor
even for a day so i'm very grateful to
her grateful to denis villeneuve for
helping us
and we're really thrilled we'll get to
celebrate her work tonight
i can't say enough how honored i am to
have her as our lead she's amazing in
the film and as for all the endless
tabloid gossip and all the noise out
there i mean the internet feeds itself i
don't feel the need to contribute i
think it's sufficiently well nourished
either way chris pine has been pulled
into this too because he said nice
things about pew in a red carpet
interview but i'm not a rapper according
to sources that twitter made up this
rubs styles the wrong way and this is
why he's now spit on the actor honestly
i think it's much ado about nothing
would there probably be absolutely
nothing to the entire thing except maybe
some bad timing who knows though and
there is constant update about the
entire thing from people saying it's the
most awkward event that they've ever
attended that's possibly because the
aforementioned drama however it may have
been worse if this is indeed a spit
spitting is such a british thing to do
as well and i actually think it's more
disrespectful than punching or slapping
someone if it had happened to me there
would have been a bloodbath at this
point oh i tell you spit against karate
but yeah it's difficult to see exactly
what happened neither have made a
statement yet but i tend to err on the
side of it being totally innocent i
might be wrong though i do think pine
probably saw something in his lap and
that may be what he's smoking about
maybe his phone is there we don't know
but what i do know is that i want to
hear your thoughts on it so make sure
you comment below again million it's
right there mate so yeah if you
subscribe it's a much appreciated by the
way thanks for singing through the video
you